kathy what were we like when we were  kids running through the house i mean i  i don't know from my perspective i  remember it i remember driving in i  remember my mom classically dropping me  off on kind of cruise in like a friday  and should pick me up like on a monday  yeah exactly  that is so classic to my mom  you had a little list i think i still do  i'm kind of hungry do you have any  chocolate chip cookies  what naughty things do you have  exactly no you kids were cute you'd play  downstairs in the big like bonus room  and you'd play ball you'd go outside in  the backyard  uh nikki would tag along  nikki would tag along but you both what  you had in common you were both you know  you were tomboys so you'd get on the  bikes and you know we had that big  driveway and  it was so cute